people invented what's called the cyclic
redundancy check terrible opening very
long but very very clever in its method
okay how does it work you're gonna need
to get a calculator out on your computer
to do this next part or Excel will do it
for you as well what the cyclic
redundancy check does is instead of
adding up all of these numbers and then
divide it okay what it does is it just
takes all of the numbers right this is
probably easy and it just Kranz them all
together into one huge number okay so in
this case the number would be I think it
was three five one one one two zero
seven one three zero four okay so this
is where the cyclic redundancy check
does is they're adding more look it just
it puts them all together in one the
buck okay in sequence right and then it
does something very simple
it divides okay so for instance it might
divide by say the same number we got
before 16 okay
and again it's gonna look for a
remainder okay now this is a very hot
number but I think your calculators
should be able to handle it can someone
tell me what's the remainder for this
after you divide by 16 what
by the way just a tip what you can do is
if you divide this right well actually
let me just do it let's hopefully this
has enough digits
okay
so I got this number right now this part
the big number I'm not interested in I'm
actually interested in the bit on the
end right because that's the putt that's
gonna give me the remainder now I
actually suspect that's all the decimal
places I've got I think it's point five
there are no trailing decimal places but
just to be sure what you do is you
subtract the big pot so I would subtract
one five and sure enough it does they
knew that okay what does that point five
mean it means I've got point five bits
of 16 left over okay so therefore the
remainder is eight okay so this gets
sent along okay as my as my crc number
okay